it is really kind of weird to see
Christmas care because if you follow her
on social media you know she is not
afraid of anything or anyone just listen
to her husband everyone's tried to clap
back to Chrissie and they've all lost
who knew Twitter could could turn into
something so funny
she's a clap bag Queen but it's all in
good fun Chrissy's giving her fingers
arrest and flexing the rest of her
comedy muscles on bring the funny she's
a judge alongside Kenan Thompson and
Jeff Foxworthy and along with host
Amanda seals they're on the lookout for
America's next great comedy act you
can't be dancin and funny like that's
just me and that's not possible and then
you were kind of the cool thing of this
show is to show there's a lot of
different ways to make you laugh you
ever become just said at any point I am
just said at every point so no okay we
want to see everybody went honestly
they're excited to laugh every time we
sit down so when you don't what do you
do that your kids think is like the
funniest thing
oh I fake yawn four-mile I don't know
why it's either like my kids are grown
so they think it's funny when I tell
them I'm not giving them any more money
[Laughter]
Chrissie is successfully crossed over
into comedy and she can see Jeff
crossing over into modeling commercial
of course I think Jeff would do like in
the high modeling wash just screams
silver-fox
yeah oh he's got like a Macy's catalog
Wrangler jeans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]